ils étaient près d'un millier à venir se
recueillir
afin d'honorer sa mémoire stéphanie mon
ferme et 49 ans et mère de deux enfants
a lâchement été assassiné vendredi dans
son commissariat parents ressortissants
tunisiens radicaliser et présentant des
troubles de la personnalité
un événement tragique mais aussi un
assaut contre les valeurs de la
république
selon la maire de rambouillet la vie
vous rambouillet avec d'une part
d'élèves la nation a perdu famille c'est
pas pour ta de la réguler le mage a
notamment rassemblé de nombreuses
personnalités politiques
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin et sa ministre délégué marlène
schiappa sont aussi venus partager leurs
émotions
la présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse est elle aussi venue
partager sa tristesse terriblement
triste aujourd'hui est terriblement
choqué
je pense que cet hommage voilà dans sa
sobriété est à l'image de cette jeune
femme et de sel la population quant à
elle affiche son soutien mais aussi son
appréhension des toons week-end j'étais
pas bien j'étais pas bien tout le week
end et c'est même là j'étais content de
reprendre l'école parce qu'on travaille
dans une école mais là c'était pas ça
aujourd'hui nous a beaucoup touché même
les enfants tout ça fait 9 élèves à
l'école sont beaucoup touché et donc
parler que de ça toute la journée que
des salles et dessins du chantier je
vais pas vous mentir shops mist parce
que parce que je pense que tous sont
français d'être optimistes voient doit
être courageux mais je suis inquiet
parce que je vois que le gouvernement
fait rien pour endiguer ce phénomène
afin de rendre hommage à leur collègue
de nombreux fonctionnaires de police se
sont rassemblées devant leurs
commissariats dans plusieurs villes de
france
un geste de recueillement et de
mobilisation afin d'afficher leur unité
face à ce genre d'événement qui peut
surgir à tout moment